[Musique]
le vietnam attendait cette visite
officielle depuis longtemps c'est la
deuxième seulement d'un premier ministre
canadien depuis 1994
justin trudeau veut profiter de cette
rencontre pour solidifier les liens
économiques avec le vietnam
mais un enjeu politique domestique l'a
suivie jusqu'ici le grand argentier du
canada stephen brown est éclaboussé le
premier ministre n'avait toujours pas
expliqué pourquoi stephen bronfman est
toujours le chef du financement du parti
libéral du canada
le milliardaire a été identifié dans les
paradise people relativement à son rôle
dans une fiducie de plus de 60 millions
dollars américains aux îles cayman par
rapport aux corps spécifiques que vous
avez mentionné
on a reçu des assurances même assurance
qui ont été dans à la déclaration
publique
justin trudeau devra aussi se concentrer
sur un autre dossier important au cours
de sa visite en asie
l'avenir du partenariat transpacifique
l'administration durable a abandonné cet
accord de libre-échange plus tôt cette
année malgré le retrait du plus
important partenaire des pays comme le
japon espère que l'entente pour entrer
en vigueur rapidement avec les onze pays
restants certains parlent même d'un
accord de principe en marge du sommet de
l'apec plus tard cette semaine nous
allons pas à être pressés pour signer un
accord à tout prix nous nous attendons à
ce que tout accord éventuel dans
l'intérêt des canadiens
en coulisses les négociateurs poursuivre
leur travail pour assurer la survie du
partenariat trans pacifique mais le
gouvernement canadien en a déjà plein
les bras avec la renégociation de
l'alena et justin trudeau a indiqué
clairement que sa priorité sera de
maintenir le libre échange avec les
états unis et le mexique
ici fait les mains sont choisis radio
canada hanoï au vietnam